[Music]
long time
[Music]
feels like I've been walking on I just
wanna let everything go and feel alright
a drum down I know we live money time we
gonna have a good time
cousin hands up to the sky we gonna get
roasted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast today is Wednesday yes
yes
September 11th which is an awful
terrible day like I hate this day with
every fiber of my being
I cry all the time I cried on the way
here watching this video on Facebook
like it's the worst day of the year it's
the worst day it's it's especially heavy
in New York there's just like an
atmosphere of sadness but it's also like
on social media like you're just
inundated with sad posts all day but I
think it really is important to be
reminded like all the time all day today
and and that like we should be sad but
we should also be strong and like
triumphant in the face of evil yeah like
you're also able to be sad not to like
turn this into like a gossip session but
like I find some of the things people
post on social media like regarding 9/11
to be so incredibly instance here and
they just like post it so that they can
say they can like just some bloggers
they follow like they were just posting
some graphic that like some person who
like works for the Huffington Post makes
you know right and I just found it to be
like didn't add any commentary to spend
it to be like insulting almost that's
actually so true like when you post
something you don't say anything new
someone else made the photo it's like
what are you trying to say here yeah I
just I honestly hate that I do joke
honestly I prefer that you didn't post
anything yeah like I want like a
heartfelt sweet message it's really not
that hard or just so you don't have to
say anything by the way yeah like you
can I usually like don't post well
actually not with stories like I
definitely do stories but but I think
people no one's waiting to hear what
this blogger has to say no but I think
people are like looking to see what
people who lived in New York at the time
like what the day was like for them you
know I was in the first grade and I
don't remember much I just remember my
teacher called it an accident she was
like there was an accident in the city
I'm like Oh a car accident yeah it was
such a weird way of expressing it but
like back then we like now it's just
like terrorism all the time right back
then it was like there was no word for
it really right so like there were no
answers as it was happening so right you
might have thought and I think initially
people did think it was an accident like
flies into a building like that
technically could be an accident that's
actually very true like the eyelet like
had a heart attack or something
but I feel like we were at a really
interesting stage because we were alive
and and I was in fourth grade so like I
was becoming a human being but I don't
like remember everything about it I just
remember being like pulled out of class
kids were leaving like one by their
Bradley Uretsky
he was the first one to leave I'm like
oh I wonder what's wrong with the green
skis the garson's I can't pronounce her
name and I was like he had a brother in
my class and they left two messages -
Matt get to leave class - yeah and then
like slowly one by one but like we were
the type of kids who never got pulled
out of school like ever there would have
to be literally 911 was the only thing
that could get us pulled out of school
and at first I was like yeah school's
out and then I remember literally
sitting our mom's bed watching TV and it
was like a difficult time because I
genuinely couldn't understand like what
was going on Oh like I'm like why would
they crash a plane into like that's evil
why would like I was just a kid I'm like
I thought I could not grab like wrap my
mind around the fact of like people
doing something so [ __ ] Evo that I
was just like I literally didn't
understand it
yeah so it's just crazy times crazy
times
crazy age to be at because we'll always
remember like where we were but I feel
like the memories get more distant yeah
actually a couple of interesting things
speaking up like because now the people
that were born in 2001 are 18 right it
means there are so many people who
actually so many kids who weren't alive
right and don't like know about the
significance of the day and so actually
Governor Cuomo just passed a law that it
is mandatory for all public schools in
New York to have a moment of silence for
the victims of 9/11 and I just think
that is a great law I gotta say
something I don't know much about
politics but I love in Cuomo these days
I do something another interesting I
just like a good American Cuomo when we
were driving home from upstate New York
um we found ourselves on a bridge I've
never been on a bridge I've never seen
the most beautiful bridge I've ever been
on
so big it like span the Hudson is called
the Governor Mario Cuomo that's not
Andrew Cuomo I don't know who Mario
Cuomo is but he built a fantastic bridge
I'm sure you Cuomo's keeping the city
together he he really isn't in like
right after you get on the bridge it
says like you are now in the borough of
the Bronx in
hat and under Bill DeBlasio and it's
like uh car starts like no but as a New
Yorker just like one is an interesting
factoid it was an interesting factoid
obviously like the bridge was so
beautiful it's like you should go out of
your way to see you know I'm talking
about the moment of silent the moment of
silence which is why here at the morning
toast we want to give a moment of
silence to all of the victims in the
fallen heroes if the first responders
the innocent victims who are just trying
to go to work and everyone in between so
we're just at work on time I know you
know yeah and those stories like freaked
me out like yeah my mom worked at World
Trade Center like you know someone would
say but you know she missed her bus you
know and it's like little things that's
like that movie sliding doors like how
one moment can change your life
yeah that that's uh freaks that gives me
chills and the move in United 93 I think
it's such a great film 100% only saw it
once because it's literally too sad yeah
I remember literally watching it and
then going to the bathroom and crying
into a towel
it was it's literally the saddest movie
it's the saddest movie and like you know
how it's gonna end and like it just
doesn't get any better and Will Arnett
it's like amazing in that movie I like
always stand Will Arnett just cuz like
he did that movie you know yeah was
Peter Herman in that movie with someone
we were talking about he should have
been I don't think so I don't they
someone else that we talk about a lot is
in that movie he talked about how we get
them confused job and like someone else
he was in United night he was yeah look
I can't with me to talk about that with
him I think we did we did I think we
didn't I think you brought it up check
because I don't even know that he's in
that no but I got amnesia that I can
that's not sure okay well I wouldn't
know that unless someone else told me so
without further ado a brief moment of
silence for the victims and heroes and
the lost lives of 9/11
I never know how long a moment should
last me neither I've never conducted a
moment of silence nobody there I just
participated like in high school like
started laughing like an [ __ ] you
know and what's crazy it's like I feel
as though on a podcast like moments of
silence are my biggest fear like right
where there's no audio no you know so
but I think that's good like a very
stark contrast of our usual show because
today was a starkly contrasting day for
a lot of American we also have regional
Lindsay on the show today yeah she is
the host of a new MTV show called
ghosted which I'm excited to hear about
with Travis Mills yeah Madeleine fetches
boyfriend oh yeah yeah there's something
Travis is it like I get confused like
because honestly and they all have
tattoos yeah if you are named Travis you
have like a long white neck with tattoos
like do you mean it's actually said you
can point that's what we're here to do
we're here to make you cry we're gonna
make you laugh honey yeah that's all we
can do yeah as being the short women
that we are truly and the short hungover
women that we are because honestly like
it is such a struggle today
these lights have never been brighter oh
right so you went out last night you did
go to the birthday party yeah you know I
was really I'm like I'm very very very
selective about what I leave my house
but I'm even more selective about when I
leave my house one week a night like I I
just that's why I don't [ __ ] with
Fashion Week like it's the worst time of
year like the most thirstiest people in
from out of town but it was Ezra
Williams birthday and a like Ivan seen
him in a long time and he's like such a
good friend and B and it was gonna be
lit you know but like I don't to say
like I just don't know but I went and
actually was really glad that I ended up
coming cuz it ended up being so fun he
had a little Kim perform at his birthday
party he saw and she better I should we
shared me sorry Kim Kardashian you get
like it look at him that's under forget
big Kim you know okay honest now take
the little and first of all what a
performer like I actually I have a
newfound respect for locates can I stand
and by the way she stayed afterwards
like she got a table at the party and
was like being so fun like she was just
a fun gal Wow love to hear it I think
that like when you do private events you
could like be doing someone's bar mitts
so I don't think she was expecting to do
a private event like where Paris Hilton
was so like [ __ ]
ended up realizing it was a cool party
and it stayed
oh that it was her through I thought
that was like a really cool thing of her
to know how we're Paris and Nicky just
you know such so like it's just like
it's shocking to me in their presence
you know what I mean like Nicky is like
so cool but she's just so she's didn't
like she's one of us but Paris is just
like literally in her own world need to
share her YouTube camera crew with her
and they were just like filming her like
dancing around the club and she like
jumped into the performance with little
kids she's just really like epic she's a
party girl like she is the party girl of
the century I don't think there will
ever be a better party girls I'm Paris
Hilton she was cool you know sisters
respecting sisters love it oh wait and
it also said Dorothy Wang and I was
talking to her about like how literally
no one can believe that she predicted on
our show that Kylie I just did you once
come back on and give a detailed like
she said everyone was so stupid like
literally there was no way but Kylie
wasn't even hiding it at all according
to Dorothy like she was very methodical
and being like perceptive she said
interesting yeah also it's the Tappan
Zee Bridge show that I was on I guess
it's been renamed the Mario Cuomo but it
has yeah but I don't recall being I've
been on the Tappan Zee Bridge before
probably no actually I don't think you
would have been on the Tappan Zee Bridge
like many times it's weird because it
like it crosses the Hudson which like so
many bridges do like even the George
Washington Bridge goes from New Jersey
the New York over the Hudson but it's
like the lands are really close so it's
really short but like up top of the
Hudson the land masses are so far away
you're on the bridge for like ten
minutes but it's a freaking it's a
beautiful view it's a beautiful Vista
and I guess it's the Tappan Zee Bridge
and people have been taking it like
forever can we talk about how incredibly
[ __ ] stupid it is to be renaming
bridges like how no not even stupid like
confusing right like okay so in New York
there's a bridge called the Triborough
bridge which is just a great bridge
because it connects Triborough say three
big roads are connected via brie there's
five boroughs in New York and three of
them are connected on one [ __ ] bridge
called the Triborough bridge and they've
recently decided to rename it the RFK
bridge and it's like all the signs say
that now it's so confusing first of all
I think it RFK connect three boroughs
right no then why is it named after no
not only that Triborough is a great
[ __ ] name a great [ __ ] name it's
like it's a jeep it's like the word
bridge it tells you what it's doing
right it's like self-explanatory
descriptive yes yes
I don't like RFK no offense whoo yeah
I'm sorry
I know JFK the Prez I know Carole runs
well there is an RFK and you know when
we're talking on the kidneys like it's
all a little touch-and-go for a second
but um if we're gonna name a bridge
after someone like I think it should be
Jessica I think it should be me but
that's a whole other conversation sure
but like no I just
Aref case just not at the top of my list
especially for such a crucial bridge a
crucial bridge I agree so just let's
stop doing that as a society okay
they're not gonna stop and Mario Cuomo
whoever you are
Congrats on the bridge man like it's
lames hope you're proud of your son
Andrew it's doing a great job down here
in New York is it his son yes it is yeah
Wow like arenas back for a nepotistic
Governor Andrew Cuomo is doing a pretty
good job I'm telling you there's more to
Andrew Cuomo than one thing than meets
the eye
yeah I'm hoping Andy Cohen with his
surrogacy law he is yeah I'm telling you
there's a lot there's a lot there's a
lot there I know he like struggles with
the MTA but I don't I can't imagine
they're an easy group to work with and
not only that there's something about
like the New York public transportation
system it's like it's never gonna work
you know like it's no one's fault that
it doesn't work it's just it was built
to fail
yeah and it's it's just too big of a
task you know there's just you know you
are always coming on this show like
telling people they're doing bad at
their jobs and like I just think we
should tell they give a moment for
Andrew am I like good job yeah and
unfortunately we voted Cuomo not home oh
so it could have been Cynthia Nixon it
could have been but you know what now
he's he's proving to us why he won right
which politicians rarely do they just
win ya know right now he's telling us
why we should have voted Cuomo not homem
exactly that is the best [ __ ]
campaign slogan like ever Snatcher
welcome back to the show thank you here
how was your diary detail than that no
you just admitted for saying it again
I'm sorry for laughing at you that time
your tie up our ball and I'm sorry for
telling everyone about it
tonight now um it was okay looking
slimmer for damn sure it was okay it's
work so that I just couldn't stop
sleeping like since I last saw you guys
except for 23 hours it sounds like a
dream yeah that sounds like it was like
what I'm gonna be doing it wasn't even
fun though it was like a painful sleep
like I was just so nauseous and sleeping
it was just not good but I'm feeling
better I'm just still tired what do you
think it was what caught the fish I
don't know either mono is developing in
my body and this is how it's starting oh
yeah or maybe just I mean it makes you a
little old for mom you want to hear
something am i it's like four teens who
are like kissing for the first time yeah
when I was isn't when I was getting like
a month ago I went to the doctor she
tested me for mono and she told me I
already had mono
well like I didn't know I remember when
people used to get mono like in middle
school and high school they just I slept
disease it was like the STD training
wheels yes very much so
one you automatically missed a month of
school like no questions asked and two
you dropped so much weight yeah and then
like you can you back and all the boys
once again yeah I missed to you you're
looking stanched yeah obviously wouldn't
we so that wouldn't be so bad
honest my throat was a little itchy this
morning I think something might be going
around who think I'm so in tune with my
body that would like something's off
just a little bit I can sniff it out no
me too
um also don't get sick because we're
going to Austin this weekend for my show
tickets available at girls night opcom
also tickets available for the rest of
my tour we're hitting up Seattle
Portland Vancouver San Diego San
Francisco Los Angeles Vancouver did I
say that already so you head over to
growth no job comm it's gonna be a great
fall we got a couple surprises you know
had a big tour meeting yesterday and I
was talking about this because the tour
has been my life your life too for over
a year and it's coming to a close in
January and like I've been really
excited about the end I will feel so
accomplished and I'm really now getting
very sad that it's ending and I don't
want to end it so I'm thinking I'm not
gonna really really I think well because
they told me you have to wait 18 months
before you go I'm talking longer you
prolong it the longer you have to wait
for the next tour
that's true and like we have plans yeah
okay so I will still end the tour in
January but
there's a few there's a few exciting
announcements by the way my girl forgot
to tell you a great meeting yesterday
and I told Jackie but I'll tell you
later just want to say if you're in the
Chicago area you might want to snatch up
your tickets no you might just want to
stay seated I'll show you later my guy
shake I know it's so annoying special
project but I assure you you will find
out what the special secret project is
and it's worth the wait sweet sweet well
without further ado I think it's time
what do you think snatcher I think it's
time but I can't believe we don't really
make the joke that much um when you say
it's time that's a New York thing
because it's firm taxi TV oh oh they
don't say that in the movie no like
you're Rochelle's segue those two lines
together
there was this commercial in the back of
taxi TVs I'm so pleased it was an
advertisement for Lion King on Broadway
and they had the one of the characters
dressed up and she said he's time ah oh
the tiffany it's a commercial yeah oh
like me that's funny maybe it's other
places too but it's a taxi TV thing for
us from New Yorkers and you know now
that we're titling our episodes like it
makes me think about what each episodes
I've been called and today I'm feeling
like the one about New York told ya you
know well you know what is a very
interesting thing sorry to cut you off I
guess she's not time it's not time
because I find it so interesting the way
and I know he's spoken about this before
the way certain TV shows like centered
around New York um I they're like
addressed or didn't address 9/11 like
Sex in the City was very much on the air
and did not Toonami truss it and I
recently found out that friends I
remember that they had episode that they
dedicated the episode that aired that
week to the people to the people of New
York the city of New York which was like
something something but then I later
found out that Monica and Chandler was
supposed to be on their honeymoon that
episode and they were all in the airport
they tried to get upgraded to first
class like the whole episode was them at
the airport and I guess they decided to
shelve that episode for a couple weeks
later due to like insensitivities you
know they just like put together this
like shitty episode oh so that was their
trivia and this episode today is also
dedicated to the city
New York and New Yorkers I like the one
with you the one about New York yeah so
just keep talking about New York okay so
now oh also one more thing about the
naming of the episodes because I saw
some people where like interesting that
they're doing friends obviously like
Claudia and Margo overruled Jackie like
because she hates her I was Jackie's
idea it was my idea it's like my
favorite and only thing that I like
about friends is the way they tied on
their episodes and it makes it so
[ __ ] easy to find and it really is
the one about this yeah so it's really
cute yeah okay without further ado it is
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast and it
is for sure like definitely we have a
lot to do rachel is who's gonna be here
but I have to let everyone know I have
to go cuz it's my job I literally get
paid to do this um today's episode is
brought to you by honey the best thing
that ever happened to me
yeah so honey is a browser extension I
actually first found out about it in the
morning Chester's Facebook group it
basically is an extension you install on
your web browser and when you're
shopping literally you're at your cart
the honey will be like hey we could save
you money want us to and you press yes
and they basically scour the depths of
the internet for promo codes coupon
codes anything free shipping any deal
that it'll apply to this website in your
particular situation and it'll
automatically discount like every time I
shop or evolve I get 15% off no totally
if you don't remember the code or search
for something in my email or like I used
to have to like search discount codes on
Google you know to like find yeah I a
million total honey does that for you
nine times out of ten you're overpaying
when you shop online unless you're using
honey they're over 10 million people
already saving with honey and they have
over a hundred thousand five star
reviews on the google chrome store Time
magazine called honey basically free
money it's free to use installed on your
computer in just two clicks and it'll
save you money so you can treat yourself
to something nice there's no reason not
to use honey so it's a free app just one
that saves you money literally couldn't
be easier there's free money it's free
money with honey so if you want to do
that get honey for free at join
honeycomb slash toast that's join honey
calm slash toast sign on and get rich
yeah sign on get your free money you
want to know another interesting fact
Twain yeah guess what I'm wearing under
my shirt today to give this is good
I'm wearing skins and it's that bra that
we took out on the show that I will
never fit me and it really does fit me
it sold out like instantly yeah I
totally see why every time I try a new
thing out of my little draw of tricks
from my schemas box
I'm Chuck I love this brassiere there's
no one good cancer okay first story
speaking of looking good amanda bynes
joins instagram again she's back Amanda
Bynes created a new Instagram account on
Tuesday amid her on-again off-again
relationship with social media bias 33
announced that she joined the platform
platform via Twitter her first and only
post so far is a mirror selfie with a
kiss face emoji as a caption in the pic
she has pink hair and a septum piercing
that's where she dyed her septum part by
the way very interesting fact is that
she's not verified okay her instrument
is at a mind Amanda Bynes reel so like
one would think it's fake one would
think it's fake just like if she did
post it on Twitter it looks so fake
amanda Bynes real unverified one post
yeah like a selfie that looks like she
did an app that like changed her hair
color another interesting fact is amanda
Bynes has an Android yeah very very
interesting and definitely segues into
one of our stories later in the show
because Apple did their big you know
song yesterday but always really means
such a big deal no they literally do
like this Apple recital where everyone
comes out he's tapped in their recorders
and like shows new phones and like there
are the same phones just like bigger and
now they have two cameras which is
pretty cool we'll get to it anyways I'm
always here for the second third fourth
fifth coming up amanda Bynes
anytime anytime we're ready we're
waiting and we're here to support
whatever she does next because like she
is a [ __ ] legend
and underappreciated rude and not taken
care of enough by the by the public by
society yeah um also whenever like I
hear an update about Ben Divine's I
always think about when she was going
for that really hard time how we
literally saw her at a party
mhm and we like stopped her we like
follow her around honestly like we were
being really inappropriate yeah we were
like being the people that we are
accusing of like not leaving her alone
yeah no totally that was us and there
was a photographer at the party it's
like a nylon party and this photographer
who I believe was a paparazzi like being
like staging it's like an event
photographer
tried a picture of her and ran out of
the building and amanda Bynes we were
following her Amanda mines literally
stormed upstairs town paparazzi a
bouncer like grabbed his poor
girl and like her camera and like
crushed her SD card and Amanda Bynes is
on her way good justice for Amanda Bynes
you guys I yeah I feel like it's on the
way to being served it's certainly not
where it needs to be service wise but I
think amanda Bynes has made some real
strides in the last few years and it's
only gonna get better for her also I
think justice for Amanda Bynes also
starts with the reckoning of Dan
Schneider which you know Royal City
we're ready weren't ready willing and
able
so whenever everyone's ready to go on
that one we're here and we'll be happy
to amplify your message the Dan
Schneider of it all is so confusing to
me because to me like Dan Schneider is
without a doubt the world's biggest
pedophile like there's no there's no way
he's not yeah I would say biggest like
physically also he has the biggest
platform most access to children and I
guess technically most successful in his
craft right now and it's also like so
deep-rooted in the Hollywood pedophilia
scene yeah um but it just shocks me that
like no one who was like there for that
time period has genuinely spoken out in
a real way and a lot of those people
still hang out with him like they were
just with him for the Zoey 101 reboot
thing like what yeah well I think it's
like no one is no one's working on it
like when something when something
starts to come out about someone then
other people come forward but like right
now as you say something I have Dan
Schneider like he still he hasn't been
cancelled like he's so respected and
like you'll get squashed so like you've
already suffered so much why are you
also gonna like now I totally understand
why people don't come forward because
like it's not it's actually not a
conducive environment even though you
think of that it would be it's like not
until some pitcher the ball is rolling
and you know Rowan Ronan Farrow starts
his article right well it's like an
easier way to come out about it yeah
because otherwise you're gonna wash like
a bug yeah
under his big butt virtus it's just a
smarty Caesar Brutus is just ask you to
Caesar everybody likes food it's just as
much at least these are sorry I said
foot I don't want to turn Dan Schneider
on wherever you are welcome for Amanda
Bynes
get that money get that coin girl you
know start selling some tea I will
support like comment follow you got it
just follow me back yeah next up
some exciting news and kind of
groundbreaking history-making because
Teddy Mellencamp is pregnant with her
third child and it's just making me
think of like have we seen a pregnancy
on the show Beverly Hills know any
housewives yeah yeah well watching
Potomac and what's-her-name
Monique is pregnant okay um but like
most of the women are in Atlanta kandi
Burruss had a kid Phaedra true Atlanta
Kenya Porsha they all know but like in
New York no one's had a child like while
they've been on the show because they're
all older past the point that Bethenny
had her show and had her child Rose
Everly Hills no OC no like it's a big
deal it's not really a big deal but I
think feeling most women come on when
they're done having children like it's
like but now we get to see someone like
as an active pregnant woman and I guess
I don't watch that oh man I think Teresa
was pregnant at what point in the
beginning when when it all started why
she yeah it was so long ago he might be
right yeah when they went on that cruise
to look at her boobies done yeah yes to
call them bubbies yeah it's been a while
no it's been a while I'm an egg again
mints yes I didn't think of it that way
I just thought it was crazy like I'm so
happy for her oh I really thought of it
that way where it's like it's gonna
bring a new dimension to the show
especially Beverly Hills where we have
not had a pregnancy yeah no it'll be
interesting I actually think it might um
like distance her from the group like
some of those ladies are so far beyond
that like point in their lives Jewry has
a little baby so oh actually that's true
and yeah but like Porsha it was like she
wants to drink right and it just it's
always a blessing but it you know it'll
be interesting to see how it plays out
ya know I think it's gonna be very
interesting that's what I'm saying and
it actually will be it'll be cool to see
someone who's like so how focused like
what she looks like
yeah and like what she does for her
pregnancy it's like a good master class
and well she'd probably do but you know
take what you can from there yeah
Congrats are in order for telling met
Teddy Mellencamp and husband Edwin
arrived oh sorry also Kim Zolciak
Biermann was pregnant
oh yeah but he's been also on her own
show Jon Housewives yeah but I guess I'm
just seeing it
in the prism of like Beverly Hills and
New York I just associate the two you
know they're just like a different yeah
I know
hey Egypt late like it's just different
the couple is expecting their third
child together The Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills star announced Wednesday
they choose 14 weeks into her second
trimester and said the pregnancy was
quote a complete surprise my husband
said I don't want to see you going
through IVF again that was brutal brutal
Mellencamp told Us Weekly it was so many
rounds but this time we really weren't
doing anything I was on vacation just
having some with my family I didn't even
know I was because I didn't have a
regular cycle the health and wellness
coaches mom two daughters slate and son
cruise she also has a ten-year-old Oh
her husband has a ten-year-old daughter
Isabella from a previous relationship
but he does yeah didn't know that either
I feel like they've kept that quiet this
is so exciting this is so exciting also
true miracle child there's nothing that
warms the cockles of my cold dead heart
more than hearing someone who like
struggled with fertility and then like
years later just like naturally gets
pregnant yeah and she had um shared her
story of when she like was pregnant with
Cherie remember it was a really sad
story where she like chose she felt a
lot of guilt around one of her pregnancy
Zoeller um I remember the details said I
want to get it wrong but this just makes
it even even though even more sweet you
know I'm very happy for her yeah Wow
counselor snitch Margo I don't know how
to tell you this but you guys yeah again
twice in one week
well would Margaret come yesterday the
last time she was on the show was when
that happened and everyone thought we
actually fired Marga yeah never okay but
you saw that my computer was closed okay
yeah maybe you need like a better maybe
we should just run from it maybe you
need a better newer computer which leads
me to my next story the five biggest
announcements from Apple's September
2019 event so as we said Apple you know
gets together and does a big performance
song and dance every year um and they
have some they have some new news but
not really Oh Jacqueline Lolita from New
Jersey was pregnant - oh yes I guess
it's like it comes you don't even
realize truly cuz I didn't you know just
comes and goes comes no but really it's
like the drinking's yeah gonna be
interesting anyways and traveling right
first interesting
factoids appletv plus one year comes
with it okay so they're new streaming
service sorry comes for free with every
new Apple device purchase okay
interesting
oh there are new streaming service they
have the morning show oh yeah and that's
all I really know yeah you know what I
want to see it also if I have an Apple
TV drag it free already because that
seems fair there right like I feel like
no though they're the Apple looks will
release new products which makes your
old products completely defective and
it's like the second thing with its new
iPhone you have the ten then just really
see 11 sorry your 10 stops working today
but it's like okay if I don't get Apple
for free then I'm just gonna keep using
my other streaming platforms which they
don't want you to do also this cost two
dollars less than the monthly cost of
what Disney Plus is gonna be Apple TV
plus will be $4.99 a month that's very
reasonable
yeah but $4.99 $4.99 a month just to
watch that one show that looks good yeah
when you paying $7.99 a month for
patreon oh five extra episodes month
we're doing a behind-the-scenes in
Austin this weekend and it's gonna be
country www.youtube.com / the morning
does okay next up they have an upgraded
seventh gen iPad which has a 10.2 inch
display who gives a [ __ ]
the Apple watch series 5 has an
always-on display that sounds annoying
iPhone 11 improves on the XR in every
way and cost six hundred ninety nine
dollars it's pretty low and yeah they
usually do like $8.99 look you can't get
out of Dodge without $1000 that was the
point they lowered the price point
that's nice doesn't mean it's shittier
well it has a dual camera system and one
of which is one of the highlights of the
iPhone 11 and they have slow-mo selfie
videos Apple is calling them slow fees
and they look amazing
okay I can just see the thirsty
instagramers who like already just like
film themselves like in their bathroom
like just using their hair you know
that's them working you know yeah and
they're like fixing their lip gloss I
could just see it now in slow-mo selfies
slow fee that's what the new camera
looks like it's a real slow piece choice
the new camera situation looks like the
Triborough bridge of cameras yep
collected all three connected all three
or the RFK bridge chip camera this is oh
it's really ugly and stupid yeah you
know what and you know I don't wanna put
out all Jim cooks work but it looks like
Lee
no it's like it must be really hard to
meet Tim Cook cuz you're always gonna be
like second best and like Apple has not
come out with something in a very long
time that's really like new and
revolutionary so they just like keep
updating on their old chin um and you
know what um I'm a slave to that bowl so
you know what like I talk a lot of [ __ ]
but I still use it but it's like this
recital is getting a little embarrassing
just to announce that your iPhone your
Apple watch these such big deals I
remember like growing up it was like
iPhone 5 it was like the biggest iPod
yeah like those things were like
historic now it's like takes place in a
little auditorium it's like pathetic ya
know with like not new updates I guess
like the newest thing they've done
recently is Apple watch which was just
like everyone had that idea we were just
like waiting for Apple to make it you
know yeah
wearable tech I would never wear an
Apple watch just saying
me neither I've only ever seen it being
used in a way one time when I was like
oh I actually think that's helpful but
still not enough for me to get it when
you're boarding a plane and know that
you can scan your phone for your
boarding pass you have a boarding pass
on your watch you literally just like
scan in so that that's not enough to
spend a thousand dollars on some stupid
ugly watch but I understood I'm like
okay people just like you're in a
meeting and someone like yeah like it's
so [ __ ] rude put your [ __ ] finger
down and talk to me no or like in
SoulCycle you can't bring your phones in
but if people are wearing their Apple
watch and they got a text like it it
brightens up and it's it's really
annoying oh that is annoying it's
probably the Texans need your watch at
the door I don't understand them I know
but people who love them I mean my
husband like loves it and I think wait
was that where's another watch yeah
all right you seen him touch it right
Jackie I don't think this actually does
sound like something he would do yeah I
think when we started dating he wore it
more and now like he has a watch that he
likes better so he's really going over
going for form over function
um but ya know I think I think he wears
an Apple watch I've like never seen I
don't think he's very gadget but what he
loves again he's not wearing Apple watch
who is he's got gadgets and gizmos
a-plenty he really really does someone
sits galore
my friend Sam wears an Apple watch but
and then we always like track our steps
if we did the same thing in the
hers is a little more accurate than mine
but like my phone tracks my steps just
fine it's unnecessary move on yeah and
like it definitely can't be good to get
constant like notifications on your
wrist when you get a text message I
think of your carpal tunnel you'll see
it when you see it you know no one needs
to be that in tune unless it might be
good for doctors we are moving at such a
slow pace today like rachel is he's
waiting for us you hear what story on we
have two more stories oh I think about
you I think we're in a good spot is she
here like yeah okay okay so she's not
here to go to hear it I do wearing a
good spot you wouldn't have someone is
ish here you know okay cool well our
fourth story I guess I've been moving
slowly because I just it's a crazy story
that's so [ __ ] weird and like I just
I don't I think I'm just gonna give my
real true thoughts on okay you know as
opposed to being like maybe PC is it
Karen Calloway no oh my god [ __ ] but we
have to talk about no loser on loser cry
okay girl power Hasbro brings gender pay
gap debate to game night with new Miss
Monopoly addressing the gender pay gap
comes down to the changing the rules of
the game that's exactly what miss
Monopoly brings to the table Hasbro is
launching a new version of the iconic
board game that celebrates female
trailblazers and is the first quote
where women make more than men officials
shared exclusively with USA Today the
new game but that's not what we want we
just want me to be equally so that's
stupid and like it's not like an old
monopoly men were being paid more than
women like honestly this is rich like on
behalf of Hasbro ricci vibe thank you
the new game which includes several
modern update including ride shares
instead of railroads at school and Wi-Fi
instead of waterworks goes on sale this
month at major national retailers for a
suggested price of $20 cool to update
monopoly Wi-Fi instead of water works by
chair instead of trains
interests odd but and I really do like
as a woman I appreciate what has much
trying to do for me but this is a big
fat [ __ ] you know for me and also it's
completely inaccurate like women are not
demanding that we be paid more than men
like we just want to be paid the same
like no more 77 cents on the dollar kind
of [ __ ] so this is pushing a false
narratives no I totally agree and I just
like I need to buy it now like how do
they how how are they how are they could
say women they're getting paid more than
men
oh I don't look at a job like it's
somewhere in the rules like if you do
something if you sell you know maybe the
billboard the boardwalk or something
yeah well I guess then it's like if
you're playing this game with a boy and
a girl
the boy is automatically out of
disadvantage just for being a boy and
then maybe he knows what it's like to be
a woman for a minute maybe but that
seems like a really [ __ ] like a really
big elaborate plan just to make a boy
feel bad guys oh boy feel bad about in
something then have a generation of boys
grow up being paid less than women and
that's not what we want and learning how
muscle is height makes an excellent
point
oh my god they're just trying to
capitalize unquote the trend of equal
pay which by the way should not be a
trap I could really agree like this is a
thirsty [ __ ] move so that we're talk
about it on the morning toast which you
know we are doing mission accomplished
um but I just like know it's a big
though for me no that's gonna be a no
for me dog
dude oh you know and like the rest of
you updates sound cool like a modern
monopoly yeah you know right and but I
just get like paid for the work that you
do it is time for a new monopoly like
yeah I actually I love monopoly like you
know but like an upgraded version like
that's more up-to-date like why are you
buying a piece of the railroad like it's
2019
okay sure it's 2019 but at least
railroad is like a tangible thing and
people still take the railroad you know
and until uh Tesla comes out with the
newest version like it's a real thing
I've been hearing Tesla's gonna make a
trade from LA to New York like when I
don't know but like I'm at least we have
the railroads like that's something
right the infrastructure just is for the
railroads they work so hard like no one
ever wants to update them no one ever
wants to take them yeah I mean they
could use like a little scrub down but I
guess I don't know whose fault that is
but they work like unlike a lot of other
things you know the Amtrak is so
reliable
yeah so something to think about we
murder took the Amtrak tuned from Boston
it was lovely lovely I love it is a
business-class seat we accidentally ends
up in the quiet car which it wasn't the
spot for us so people wouldn't that
must've been hard for you it's not sure
you couldn't be so chatty yeah why not
is
right I know cuz you hate us now like
your only one hanging out like with your
friends you don't hang out with us
anymore so yeah you're not a chatters
need us yeah and you're not as chatty
because we haven't taken a long ride
together but the Italian maybe in Oslo
is just a lot of long rides coming up
between Portland and Seattle and then
Seattle Vancouver we have like in the
span of a week like three three-hour
drives and I'm looking forward to the
conversation blowing here's an
interesting point does Hasbro even pay
their female employees at the company
equally to men this is what I'm talking
about
Hasbro is one of these companies with
their [ __ ] HR [ __ ] you know yeah
I need you to look in the mirror at the
top yeah this shaving your games stop
playing games with my heart yeah this
isn't a game Hasbro yes is our lives
hysterical
this isn't a game and like I'm sorry as
a woman making more than my male
counterparts while we're playing
Monopoly like does absolutely nothing
for me yeah also it's like oh this is
what something might be like it's
depressing and then they'll be like oh
you just won because you're a woman like
you I want our in the win oh right and
then it's like whoever wins has more
whoever has more money wins and then
like the girl wins because she gets paid
more and then it's like you handed it to
her women aren't even so what do you
think has grown women aren't smart or
strong enough to actually do it
themselves you need to give them a leg
up
yeah we're not trying to spin the wheel
in the other direction we're trying to
break the wheel oh my god this is so
incredibly stupid and in fact the
Kremlin's story not only someone that
multiple people thought it was a good
idea is what shakes my core yeah women
are getting two hundred and forty
dollars when they pass go and get two
hundred when they pass go so they want
mint I don't know if that's true but
like that may that sounds about right
that sounds so stupid yeah I told you
that I have this stupidest story of all
time today you did say I didn't I didn't
fail you didn't fail okay pick the final
story a little is news that you are
gonna find particularly interesting but
before we do that
chase biz news is brought to you by zip
recruiter hiring sponsor hiring can be a
challenge
as codable co-founder gretchen hübner
discovered gretchen needed to hire a
game artist for her education tech
company she knew wouldn't be easy to
find someone to grow with her team
that's why she went to zip recruiter so
zipper cuter it's like an online
platform where you can help fund
candidates for a job you're hiring for
so if you're doing freelance you know
our company's constantly looking for
like video editors merch designers
anything simple Cooper is a big online
platform filled with resumes to help
match you with the perfect candidates
they have screening questions to filter
candidates so you can focus on the best
ones the zip recruiter is affected for
all businesses of all sizes try zip
recruiter for free at our address zip
recruiter comm / toast
that's zip recruiter comm / toast VIP
recruiter our ICI ruit are.com / toast
TOA st if you grow your business looking
to expand as some fellow entrepreneurs
we can let you know we've used it
recruiter great platform for candidates
they get high quality candidates make it
super easy can be overwhelming on some
other platforms zip recruiter is the
place to be that's a good-looking little
jingle for the commercial
a quick question for super cute aromas I
was like I know that I love seeing
actually commercials for our sponsors on
TV because one like just we see each
other and - like it's nice to see how
they promote their like you know
anything you should be highlighted right
yeah been fine story white cloth truly
and other heart shelters could take a
hit from sober September this is from
exactly this is from MarketWatch you
guys Smart Watch is stupid okay they're
watching the market though yeah and I'm
watching them so temer could be a long
difficult month for hard seltzer brands
if young consumers make good on their
intentions to participate in sober
September says EBS analysts okay you
guys like it's love and love it and make
a wish um I wish for happiness for the
9/11 families it's 11
I wish for the same thing as well and I
wish for my hangover to go over do you
argue very incredibly like I'm gonna
drink a lot yeah like you have fun you
are anything over big time I want to say
Chevy worse I threw up last night oh
great okay cool
yeah then I showed my face with a couple
toasty toes drink some water hit the hay
Dumanis you're doing like a great job of
playing you doesn't mention oh my
I didn't even usually like your
sunglasses hat your missus hat I'm just
like I'm not in the mood to be dramatic
I'm literally too tired you know II mean
yeah I understand
hard Seltzer's sparkling water spiked
with alcohol have had a busy summer with
recent media reports of a shortage of
the popular white cloud Rand sober
September something I have never heard
of as a young person I've heard of dry
January of course and like No Shave
November he a month-long abstinence from
alcohol could put an end to the good
times of all of their respondents to the
latest gb/s evidence lab survey make
good on their plans to start autumn off
with a dry spell that is not a thing
market watch ups I can tell you this
will completely like not affect any of
these brands honestly their sales
michael up and here's a [ __ ] report
and this is like why everything is
[ __ ] ubs pulled 1055 US alcohol
drinkers with more than a third saying
they were quote very likely to
participate in silver September this
year well no there's another nineteen
percent said they were somewhat likely
who the [ __ ] did they ask like not
toaster I'll tell you that much yeah no
not real human beings I can I'm
predicting it now okay I'm watching the
market white claw truly and other hard
Seltzer brands will be completely
unaffected by the upside okay you know
what this is actually great because if
you are like in the stock game um people
will probably sell their shares of hard
alcohol companies because they think
it's gonna go down because they're gonna
have a bad mouth she kidding but we know
that nothing is gonna change it all and
also like even though it's technically
September and fall is approaching like
the weather is still just as nice as it
is in the summer and people are actually
getting their last licks in like they're
not they're not stopping their legs yeah
they're still looking look at it up
right the counselors speech what are
your friends doing since you're always
with them my friend did not really I'm
hard seltzer drinkers hey Rose walk like
let's take a minute like I've got no way
matter that's like you spoke to me all
week I should they say call we should
they send literally all the time that is
beeping
I'm better to [ __ ] knock down the
studio next door I'm [ __ ] I think you
should go in there because we always
think want to yell at everyone who's
like interpreter it's literally in here
like the liquid courage hangover yeah
I'm literally cracking skulls also it's
football season people are drinking more
like who writes this [ __ ] Hasbro I can't
like what do we do it no James this is
Jake second time gonna yell at someone
what did you mean seriously
no I how is it too loud this year this
business yeah this is a place of like at
live entertainment show Chuckie this has
to be the one with the beeping I'm sorry
no but like can people hear it yes yes
we're like is there a forklift in the
studio apparently yeah no they're about
to like come in from the back no it's
gone no - no it's just getting further
away also I don't even know like what
did I bring the camera let's go on
location yeah nobody like this is like
those so grab that tripod can you stop
that could we actually take the camera
it's wire net it's happening you know
these TV shows that's like you catch
someone doing something bad they like
new big duck jump yeah phobias you're on
candid camera canon camera okay everyone
back to market watch um
yeah I'm calling [ __ ] on this I'm
calling dibs on you lips
did you see Kelsea Ballerini posted a
picture she went to Jonas Brothers
concert and hung out with them
afterwards and then she did a swipe
through to this video she made when she
was like eight about how she wanted to
weigh the Jonas Brothers meet-and-greet
and she's like I would say Janet's
bothers about songwriting
because I love to sing it would be
amazing to see someone you know who's
living their dream and performing songs
that they were in it was honestly
hysterical she like had braces and she
was like in her bedroom honestly I feel
like if I ever really got famous and
they would like need footage of me like
fur documentary like I had no memories
it was like weird photo good things like
I don't
oh my laptop's are gone but we have Home
Videos and stuff I know the beeping it's
gone but like I still hear it in my head
like it's like it's a giving me like I'm
PTSD sorry it was so loud okay really
quickly before I'm wearing a Rachel and
saying we need to talk about Caroline
Calloway
okay and you know that we've spoken
about her on the show before yes because
she had like the fire festival of like
single white female influencer events in
old tickets to something that didn't
exist I believe she deemed the toast
when we spoke about her and wanted to
come on but we had just gone on break so
I'm like no I don't really care but yeah
everyone's talking about basically if
you don't know the story it's a little
too long-winded just to explain but
basically there is a girl who was like
one of the first big influencers and
she's just become known recently as like
scam artists because everything she does
his scamming vibes like she got a huge
book deal I'm like one of the first
foreign influence there was like such a
big deal and she like did a bunch of
adderall never at the book and then I
think she has I gave her advance back it
was like over three hundred thousand
dollars yeah so then she just became
known for that and then she became known
for this festival she tried to put on
like she sold tickets $200 they get good
prints yeah to bug women's empowerment
where they were gonna make flower crowns
I like mason jar like flashlights and
she didn't even have a venue she sold
tickets didn't have a venue ended up
having to move it it was like begging
and yelling at people to just take the
train from Philly and come to New York
like it was so crazy then she like made
gift bags for all the attendees and she
ordered 1200 mason jars to her studio
apartment and like this amazon truck
jacqui this might be huge like a box it
it was like 19 it was a crate that they
delivered to her tiny apartment of 1,200
mason jars so she could make gift bags
for all of her attendees and now she's
in the news again because apparently and
i guess not everyone knew she had like a
silent partner in in her instrument how
she got famous was she had like an
instagram called adventure grams or she
would travel around the world and write
these crazy elaborate captions and this
girl natalie was a girl she met at NYU
was the mad I don't know but I I can
barely hear it so you know it's just I
don't know if I'm going [ __ ] nuts in
my brain oh yeah or if I'm just here
okay so this girl Natalie wrote an
article for the cut explaining how she
was really like the ghostwriter of all
these captions and like worked for
Natalie because shake Natalie was like
this cool a rich girl that she met while
at NYU and like Natalie was I'm sorry
Caroline was like this cool rich girl
that she met while NYU and Natalie
needed money and thought Caroline was
cool and worked with her for years until
the
dissolution of their friendship a little
while ago but that article was full of
interesting factoids about like Caroline
literally living like the Anna Del V
life like yeah he was real scabby vibes
and everyone is now like just like dying
and like turning on Caroline Callaway
and she deserves to be turned on but
there was a huge like um seeing no one's
talking about that's really bothering me
because I would when I read the article
I'm like yeah Carolyn Callaway is a scam
artist and she's weird but this girl
natalie is a big [ __ ] Lizzie I have
so many thoughts about this first of all
when we talk about this person Caroline
Calloway like she was the original
influencer but like no one I never heard
of her you had never heard of her no one
and I'm sure we're telling you story now
and people are like what who why it
turns out she bought all of her
followers at the time so like literally
five people actually know who she is
like now she has like 700,000 followers
she gets less than a thousand likes on
some photos she doesn't have like like
it's just it's a it's a complete farce
and it's like we're talking about
someone who has like made herself famous
but like has no Fame and like has no
influence and has no real followers so
it's like we're all talking about this
person that no one actually knows then I
read this article and like I don't know
what the like the big expose was just
supposed to be talking about how this
girl like squandered this opportunity
that was actually like all built on
fakeness which actually just goes to
show how like people in the industry and
like the people who gave her a book
dealer [ __ ] [ __ ] like I'm totally
and that's my she ruined book deals for
every like internet bloggers for the
next five years like they've ruined them
for themselves like you don't do any bit
of research like how many likes does she
get how many comments does she get it's
so [ __ ] easy to see who has influence
and who doesn't like so if you work at a
publishing house and you're in a
position to give someone at like a three
hundred fifty thousand dollar advance
like you have way too much power because
you can't even do the bare minimum of
work right like seeing that they bought
followers right like seeing that this
person has no story and like is not
interesting and doesn't have a real fan
base that's beside the point
then her ex friend like writes this
whole expose on like how this girl was a
farce which we all sort of knew if we
even knew who she was
so like thanks for giving her a platform
again on the cuff yeah because still we
don't know who she is and like the
friend and it's like I want to feel bad
for the friend because like she was
written out of history hidden figures
etc um but she's a big [ __ ] loser and
like
whole attitude towards life is losery
and it's like it's just loser on loser
crime yeah just don't care so true and
like I feel like now everyone's talking
about the article like Natalie's article
poor Natalie and let's like yeah poor
Natalie but like Natalie put literary
person up in that situation and like
knew exactly what she was doing and like
took advantage of Caroline honestly
honestly I'm kind of on Caroline side
it's like like of course like this girl
was so desperate to be Caroline's friend
and like wanted to like wipe her ass
what are you what something like the way
she talks about like a house she knew
Carolyn was lying about certain things
but she just kept going on with it like
she just wanted to be her friend she
wanted to me except it's like it's cool
than in hindsight she can admit that she
was a huge [ __ ] loser but like are we
supposed to feel bad for you and like
why are we blaming Caroline for Natalie
being a loser like I just thought that
was so weird I'm like now I'm saying
everyone talked about this situation
like no one's really talking about how
it's like you like like you were not you
weren't like you did this Natalie like
you were the loser like you flew across
the world with someone who barely knew
me and like you had a terrible
experience yet you stayed for another
month feeling badly right and you also
like we're enjoying all the perks like
she almost ought you say in her
apartment that she had to air B&B oh you
weren't you enjoying all the perks all
the good weed and adderall
of being Caroline's friend yeah and like
the way she talks about their time
together it was like Blair and Serena
like on the yeah I of friendship and
love and adderall and it's like so you
were having a good time with your friend
and so I thought the most interesting
part was the Gail plates because and a
kind of new talent actually actually no
Natalie really described there are
people who I know who am like friendly
with but like not more than like surface
friendship where they just lie about
everything in like you literally know
their line too but you just like let it
slide because it's not worth I being
like oh you're wearing the ring now you
don't need yeah and I totally can you
slowly back away from Brenda you don't
give them their time your brain your
energy in your love and then like wonder
where they went right but I thought it
was a like she's actually good writer
this girl Natalie and I really like the
way she described that type of person
like I actually knew exactly I had
someone in mind
and it's like I know girls like that
like from Collina stuff either
never like close friends with them yeah
but then it also makes you think okay so
you knew exactly who she was like you
literally continue the friendship for
five years like you're and like anyone
that I know who like became close with
like a person that I knew who's like a
klepto crazy [ __ ] like and then wonders
where their friendship went I'm like
you're the [ __ ] loser yeah and it's
like I know she needed the money but
you're a college grad girl like yeah and
like clearly she's smart yes she's a
great writer yeah like I don't know it
was it's such a depressing article it
was so loser I could I feel like a loser
for talking about these it's like it's a
movies are by association like no we're
better I feel like I wasted my time
reading it like I wasted my time going
to Caroline's Instagram to even try and
understand why people might follow her
only to learn that people actually don't
follow her right so like we're talking
about a random person who tried to prop
herself up but really is just like
anyone else with an Instagram and
gratuitous leave long captions right no
one needs to [ __ ] read no so then
then it makes you think like okay no one
even cares about Caroline because she's
not real why would why they care about
her silent friend why would I care about
the person who gave us all these
captions that we don't ya know such a
weird article this is like such a weird
trend that people are talking about and
it's bad for the influencer community
and I'm ashamed looks like I'm not
because this is not an influencer this
is a grifter do you know what I mean
like yeah if a real influence are like
something Navy like does something where
she got some book deal and she couldn't
deliver she had a clothing line it sucks
like that's that's bad book on the
influencer community because she's a
real influencer and then I will you know
hang my head in shame but while a
wannabe and her wannabe friend like just
continue to be wannabes no it's not the
word wannabe the word is loser like but
how would you pronounce it like I mean
if I had to you know put it in specific
pronunciation I would probably say this
is the most oh sorry
story I've read in munson also though
this story I read a month okay I know
but like that's what you spent your time
on I know but I really did like Ben was
talking me and like I literally can't
talk to I have to read this incredibly
long hard I have to be this incredibly
article because I think it's gonna go
somewhere right and then ready to go
nowhere yeah it is time to bring out
Rachel Lindsay we're gonna take a quick
if you want to go get a snack use the
bathroom turn to Sally at the
watercooler you go do that if you have
any questions for Rachael Lindsey drop
them on Instagram or on YouTube and we
will do our best to get them to her see
tuned to take a break be our
[ __ ] be peace
you
we are back with friend of the show
newlywed a host and now you have your
own new [ __ ] show on MTV like there
are too much I don't have enough fingers
to say I'm on the podcast hide a suppose
means so much to catch up with Rachel
Lindsay I was so low on you are now are
you gonna become rich sob solo yes
illegally not professionally I'm Sophie
Rachel that's so funny like I never did
any of it but I definitely don't want to
do illegally like the paperwork torture
I haven't done it yet you can't travel
like out of the country could you teach
wait for your passport it's just like
knocking me out of it honestly because
it ain't worth it we're feminists we're
like trying to get women not to do it I
just like changing it in places where
like on Facebook like yeah I need to get
my cell you changed it on Instagram yeah
I just like to see each to each
experience system yeah I mean we're
married so you know it is what it is how
was the wedding
oh yeah bet it was so good it was
beautiful it we had a blast we had so
much fun family and friends just
celebrating love I just wanted a big
party like Mikey thank you for those of
you don't who don't know Jackie gave me
Mikey her wedding planner and he did not
disappoint
no he's hilarious yeah you know I
performed the trackies wedding and Mikey
was very assured he said to Katie he was
kidding me tea all day I was being like
a little bit of a diva he was really
great
he's really great I'm so glad he loved
him like I'm so glad it worked out yeah
I didn't have a vision so I was just
like yeah I just want to have fun and he
was like okay that's not gonna work it's
not a vision he helps me you know get
the color scheme we decided on the
tropical wedding he put it all together
so everything you saw that's all Mikey
oh my god that's amazing I'm so happy to
hear that it looks so beautiful looked
so fun and like lit and just so you guys
yeah yeah we partied it up well we have
a lot to talk to you about but one thing
I need to talk to you about is something
that you may come at me for saying but
like I just need to know why Raven
wasn't at your wedding like I think
you're gonna I'm sorry because you want
to know why like I ship you and Raven
yeah and I don't know everyone is up in
flames like what the [ __ ] happened
you weren't she was on your bachelorette
party oh my god well maybe they're not
that close anymore this she wasn't the
wedding and I was like there's me
there's me this is what I will say Raven
and I are not friends
no and I promised I wouldn't talk about
it okay you know all
say is she knows what she did okay you
know and you can ask her maybe y'all can
have her and she'll talk about it but
we're not friends so maybe I've never
spoken about it so that honestly that's
really respectful I like that thank you
thanks for being respectful yeah I'm not
gonna go to Twitter and say fickle and
fleeting again I'm just gonna these
Bachelor friendships are fickle and
believe it honestly you need to make
merch fit go in a pleated you guys like
you guys how you know you're a love DSS
necklace it's like sick of it yeah
shit's trademark that really you really
should I need to be on that so I've
matured over Geyer so I'm not gonna say
anything that's there you know what I
actually like that I hate when people
like air their journey long I mean I
love it but like it's so tacky
yes so many Bachelor friendships that
are not fickle and fleeting you have so
many bachelor girls at your wedding
party your wedding your what bachelor
party looked everything yeah it was fire
I just wanted girls to go wild yeah and
they do I'm no men allowed yeah well
except for my friend Wayne who couldn't
make it
yeah we just partied it up and in a safe
place and that's what I wanted people
who weren't gonna like out me on the
ground yeah we could get wild Ratched I
mean it was the ratchet Laurette it was
the rat I thought it was good you know
what that it has two meetings the Rachel
are at I'm Rachel are at my dad Chet I'm
a genius big reason to name that we can
we all have campaigns we kind of you
know it was very toasty
that's why I was attending but you are
here because your new show on MTV
premiered last night which is so crazy
like I just can't believe you're truly
taking over the world called ghost ed
your co-host which I just found out this
morning cuz I was singing like that guy
looks so familiar
he's Madeline patches boyfriend I know
he is like I mean he's a name and like
whether they're like criteria but like
being that on catches boyfriend it's
like good enough for me Travis Mills
Travis Mills yeah tell me about what
it's like to film a TV show well that's
not the bachelor right where I'm the
Chris Harrison right do you see a lot
more though and yes Harrison yeah you're
a little more beautiful oh thank you
guys
shadows Chris Harrison of Travis is
fantastic like the two of us hit it off
like really quickly I did his podcast I
was a guest we started talking about
dating ghosting and we were like this is
a thing we really need to do some
yeah so we partnered up with in TV and
we're hitting the road telling all these
ghosting stories it's tiring yeah sure
filming a TV show I'll just start with
the negative first but it's so much fun
you know like getting to know the
haunted that's what we call them
figuring out investigating why they got
ghosted talking to their family their
friends finding out all these stories
like the tea is hot trying to say I just
love that you're like keeping people
accountable for ghosting people it's
about the other thing to do honestly
yeah it is and it's becoming acceptable
yeah well no more because they will out
you they will apply and put you in a
show that's like what catfish did for
catfishing like people are now less
likely yeah because they're gonna say
that wasn't even showing up in my house
you know now you don't want big rates
showing up at your house oh did you get
a tips from Nev have you met him no I
haven't think you need to I think so too
yeah because our concept our little
similar like me a docu-series but
they're different
I thought ghosting is more relatable
it's extremely bright I can't relate to
someone who honestly like starts an
online relationship with someone they've
never met and has one picture like
that's just on me but I've been ghosting
before my friends family but I've
questioned to every think it's
appropriate to go someone like when a
relationship is short enough that it
doesn't like require like letting
someone know that it's over but it's
just like goodbye I think I'm actually
yeah bro ghosting but if you like the
cases on your show are like we were in a
relationship we have a family and you go
similarly ships are open like when
relationships are in the newest stage
and like someone just goes to you like
it's just not worth the conversation
like sometimes I feel like I mean I get
it I I feel like everybody deserves some
type of conversation like even if it's
like wasn't fill in it by yeah just so
much they're not wondering but we don't
do any stories where it's like I went on
one date right I disappeared that's
called a one-night we don't take those
cases and I think the shocking thing was
when I was ghosted because the guy had a
whole family on the side yeah hmm shout
out to my muse that's just why I've been
telling a story over and over
we're actually really cool but I didn't
know how deep it was with family members
and friends and I just can't imagine a
friend ghosting me like that and that's
a lot of the stories that we do on the
season frightened ghosting hmm first day
wow that would sated to watch the whole
season you'll love it it doesn't
disappoint I'm excited for you
Thank You chef fighting endeavour you
aren't one of the hardest-working people
you know like you just launched a
podcast yes what is that like being a
fellow podcaster it's different you guys
gotta come on the show yes we've already
at the snatchler obviously that artwork
my body a [ __ ] is in trouble I was
proud no I know it's actually so funny
I'm so glad you brought that up so we
obviously someone hadn't made like a fan
art of Margo on your body because like
she had this picture of her in the red
dress and it was just like so beautiful
so when we were putting together a show
we're like obviously we're gonna use
that and like nobody would have cared
just about the soda podcast but because
you put it on your Instagram I gots flag
by Warner Brothers and it got taken down
off of iTunes for copyright this girl
Berry at Warner and then I got an email
like Gary at Warner Brothers calm like
literally took a town copyright
infringement I'm surprised I didn't cos
like such torches Sony attack we had an
artist make a recreation original art of
you address so we got it back I'm just
cutting she's my competition it was so
funny but you got us in trouble
that was my bastard play obviously worth
the promotion worth the promotion for
sure question for you what are you gonna
do now that bachelor in paradise is
ending next week do you guys take a
break are you gonna still just talked
about your people on the podcast yeah
we're gonna we're gonna I can see like
oh no cuz Ali and I have different
perspectives just about love and life
and we're gonna bring different people
on from The Bachelor franchise and maybe
even behind the scenes like really good
friends with a stylist from the show so
maybe we'll have him come back - great
idea
yeah
no one feels by the way you look
beautiful on your seasoned you a lot of
input in like what you got to wear or
you just let go and said put me in stuff
know that I I had a lot of input and I
think that's a big misconception which
is why I want the stylist on the show
because everyone will say oh my god
that's so tacky and it's like you need
to be blaming the lead right we walk
into a room racks of clothing and we
pick the clothes that we lay those like
the stylist just gets the clothes there
so the style is truly the lead style so
if you're a fan of the lead and what
they're wearing that's all man that's
interesting because I was like this guy
what's his name Carrie right yeah like
he is doing how to Brown no justice in
these dresses like so like matronly and
ugly but I guess that's just a mascara
and that's you know Shay but I mean she
truly picked her own clothes yeah I
thought like every time I saw her I was
just like let down and let down oh I
like her style no no me neither very
basic you looks great yeah that is an
interesting yeah you should definitely
have like more like a logistical
behind-the-scenes people actually but
truly it is interesting idea because
it's a different perspective yes how
many times have you seen us come on and
talk over and over about the franchise
you know you've got the usual ya usual
bunch yeah I don't want to talk to them
no and I find that the behind the scenes
like logistics is so much more
interesting like I think there should be
a whole episode dedicated to how you
travel when you're on The Bachelor like
when you're the leave you sit in first
class right yes but when you're not you
sitting coach you do but you're all on
the same flight not with Aletha oh
you're not they travel before you with
Chris Harrison yeah Chris Harrison
Ilan Bennett right when it was Ilan
right your producer so that's what he's
been so close to Chris Harrison because
you're traveling with him mm-hmm
interesting scene that could be a whole
episode like that I find super
interesting yeah and the girls have to
all fly together they hate each other no
they don't hate each other
no that's the drama you and Vanessa you
don't own one flight they set us next to
each other and I was like stop it
anybody wanna trade you know we're cool
now are you yeah really I have no
problems with her you're like a
problem-free carefree gal but I get a
rep that I am because I got your
friendships are fickle and sail in
fleeting and I
say the things that people won't say
yeah I mean how boring is it to be like
sunshine and blue skies all that's you
know I said we are a founding member of
the toasts for sure you guys I love you
I'm so happy for you sure the show
premiered last night it's on Tuesdays at
what time nine o'clock nine o'clock on
the tree Bay in Pacific I didn't
understand the whole Eastern Central
Pacific that's all I can say
Yeah right I find that incredibly
confusing so just watch that nine
o'clock it's easy for us honestly The
Forgotten people are people into my baby
yeah how is that I'm trying to get used
to it honestly it's not my vibe yeah
it's an in-and-out City right yeah it's
totally different to live there yeah do
you think you're gonna stay there for a
while I don't think so we're you ready
to go next LA yeah honestly Dallas I
feel like you guys should have moved to
Dallas Dallas is such a great we just
spent the weekend there it's about isn't
it great we did for two years but
career-wise with LA is in between
everything or New York yes it's just
room I mean LA it's actually just as
expensive so you could do either but you
get I feel like you get more space at
least and I yeah and it is cheaper is it
it's yeah like Miami yes let me see I
wouldn't advise New York like the tally
the honest it sucks air control here
we're trying to get out maybe we should
say Miami there's no income tax no but
neither one jealous no no bit edges I
think LA I think yeah big time yeah in
taxes tax further yeah honestly maybe I
should say about me just for that reason
alone all right
well Brian will love that yeah well I
was married life married looks great
we're like two and a half weeks in we're
still on cloud nine it is amazing it was
better than I thought I wanted to do
Greece and Italy huh
we couldn't have done both yeah Greece
is exactly what we needed we learned
Santorini azar vibe we've missed the
train on Mykonos we're too old for me no
also I've been hearing a lot of negative
things about mikonos recently I think
like the time is up four times up on me
yeah like is it because there's so much
crime it just is like it's unsafe yeah
we got in and out
let's move in here I can't believe that
you went on your honeymoon right after
your wedding like that's so ideal but
like I look it's years later selling
online
you have no it's efficient we need I
have to get it done before football
season yeah I'm always working he's
working I have a new radio show so it's
like I got back Sundays I've already
done one outside I'm not gonna hit the
radio at all
how do you really do it all like how do
you balance everything I don't I'm going
on fumes I'm exhausted
yeah jambe yeah yeah I don't even know
where I am
no you're go I love you Lindsey I'm so
low more than anything on planet earth
follow her watch her on ghosted
Tuesday's 9:00 p.m. central whatever
[ __ ] on MTV follow her on Instagram
listen to her radio show do her podcast
support this [ __ ] because she supports
the toast and she respects the hell out
of the morning toast which is all you
can really ask for in a guest this glow
dance because I couldn't decide between
one Thank You lane he hooked it up ago
he did because I wanted mixed mouth yeah
yelling [ __ ] Oh same thing I'm gonna do
a pink middle band like hopefully for
one year and that's it's really cute
yeah yeah must be a Mikey thing just us
a couple married girls talking shop oh
my god sorry sorry single ladies
yes thanks so much listening to the
morning toast Milano Morning Show we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on you - mmm are also
available spot guess anywhere pockets we
found I'm so hungover I need to head off
this chair I have a great day everyone
we will see you tomorrow
we are waiting this natural right now
it'll be up later today so head over to
the podcast or the snatchler
you